avec nous il ya simon professeur de
stratégie à la faculté des sciences de
l'administration de l'université laval
bonsoir bonsoir questions très simples
messieurs simon
devrait-on nationaliser air canada la
réponse rapide et que non c'est à dire
qu'il faut répondre par la négative à
cette question là parce que les
gouvernements historiquement ont
toujours eu beaucoup de difficultés à
être de bons opérateurs de lignes
aériennes par ailleurs faut voir qu'il
ya quand même des coûts importants et
des inefficiences sont associés à ces
activités-là lorsqu'elles sont prises en
charge par le gouvernement
il reste donc la nationalisation pure et
simple au total devrait être la dernière
option ceci étant dit il ya des raisons
qui font que certains types de
nationalisation partielle peuvent avoir
lieu
pensez à l'argument du maintien d'une
capacité nationale ou encore l'argument
du métier d'une capacité de service des
pays comme l'italie ou le portugal
en ce moment font des avancées en ce
sens alors est-ce qu'on devrait aller
vers ça est ce qu'on veut de lequel quel
type des d'aucun type de soutien ou
d'intervention pourrait être avancée il
y en a plusieurs c'est à dire que par
exemple aux états unis on a choisi de
faire un ensemble des aides qui
totalisait 50 milliards divisé en deux
tranches de 25 milliards ou une tranche
de 25 milliards était destiné à du
soutien à l'emploi et l'autre tranche
était destiné à du soutien donc sous
forme de prêt maintenant il ya plusieurs
autres alternatives c'est à dire que le
gouvernement pourrait choisir de prendre
une participation partielle ou
simplement de donner des aides
évidemment c'est très difficile de
donner des prêts lorsque l'entreprise
bon on a des limites quant à ces actifs
mais il reste qu'il ya là une piste de
solution
sauf que bien évidemment dans ce type
d'opération da silvia la question de
l'acceptabilité sociale qui est
importante
d'une part et d'autre part il faut aussi
s'assurer qu'une équipe de gestionnaires
en place tu sois bien au fait des
contraintes qui viennent
avec le gouvernement du québec lui parle
de subventionner monsieur legault a
parlé de subventionner des compagnies
existantes aujourd'hui est ce que ce
sera une bonne approche
ça pourrait être une approche
intéressante pour maintenir une capacité
de service il ya des entreprises qui se
sont montrés intéressés qui sembleraient
avoir la capacité de prendre en charge
ces services là évidemment la grande
inconnue c'est la demande
il ya assez peu de demandes en ce moment
c'est ce qui explique la raison derrière
l'arrêt de service d'air canada
bon il ya la demande y aussi les aspects
financiers mais il reste que faut pas se
leurrer c'est très très coûteux à
l'heure actuelle d'opérer une ligne
aérienne air canada brûle 22 millions de
liquidités par jour où elle a perdu un
milliard au dernier trimestre en termes
de liquidités donc il ya là quand même
une logique qui fait que beaucoup de
pays choisis spécialement dessus
mentionnée mais aussi d'y aller par des
formules de prêt avec des taux d'intérêt
variables et des niveaux de risque
variable justement pour aider les
entreprises à passer à travers cette
antenne comme c'est le cas en france air
france la france a injecté 10 milliards
la dent dans l'air france pourquoi
ottawa ne va pas dans ce sens là avec
une décision avec une approche précise
direct pour aider air canada et toute
l'industrie aérienne
mais dans le cas de la france il ya une
longue tradition de venir en aide à air
france dans le cas d'air france klm
il y à des coupures de postes qui ont
malgré tout été annoncée en dépit de
l'aide qui a été accordé et ça crée
beaucoup de ressentiment aux états unis
dans la tranche de 25 milliards d'êtres
company dont on parlait tout à l'heure
pour le soutien à l'emploi
il ya une conditionnalité qui était
attaché c'est à dire le refus de baisses
de salaires et de mises à pied
d'employés d'ici le 1er octobre mais les
entreprises sont déjà à pied d'oeuvre
pour vient signaler à leurs employés
lesquels devront se restructurer
american airlines est la dernière
et donc on voit que ce type de mécanisme
n'a peut être mis en place pour éviter
des désagréments si on veut mais il
reste qu'ils ne sont pas parfait parce
que la logique économique fini par
rattraper les entreprises et les
gouvernements qui souhaitent venir en
aide à ses entreprises
alors la logique économique comme vous
dites est ce qu'elles cadrent avec le
désir d'occuper le territoire de
développer nos régions de garder des
liens avec des régions éloignées qui
sont des lignes où il y aura jamais
énormément de demande et qu'ils seront
toujours déficitaire oui tout à fait et
dans lequel air canada air canada
pouvait s'acquitter de cette tâche
disons qu'ils étaient effectivement peu
rentable parce qu'il y avait les
liaisons internationales vont penser aux
liaisons transpacifiques
transatlantiques avec des bonnes
capacités de classe affaires qui sont
disons le la vache à lait des lignes
aériennes classiques et qui permettait
justement de pouvoir maintenir ce type
de service là un peu moins rentables au
bilan avec l'effondrement des bons des
liaisons internationales et ben je dire
la gravité fini par nous rattraper
c'est à dire que comme n'y a pas
suffisamment de liquidités qui sont
générés et des activités qui génèrent
des coûts importants sont généralement
les premières à devoir être arrêté et
dans ce cas ci c'est malheureusement ce
qui s'est produit
ainsi il y avait éventuellement une aide
gouvernementale assortie d'une
réglementation appropriée
il y aurait peut-être une place pour
qu'un grand comme air canada continue ce
type de liaison là mais l'équation
économique mais tout simplement pas du
tout
en tout cas les discussions sont en
cours avec air canada nous dit on au
gouvernement du canada et au
gouvernement du québec on va suivre ça
de près bien sûr yan cimon merci ça me
fait très plaisir 23 rien à voir